good morning john we had a great chat on
the phone this week and i want to hit
you with
insights that i feel like we have we
know and we talk about together and that
we have almost developed together over
the years
but i don't know that we've talked about
it like each one of these led to the
next
and i think it's useful it's been useful
for me i think though it's hard to tell
for sure number one it is really hard
maybe impossible to stop
wanting things but also like is it
actually good to not want anything like
i wanna wanna live
i want to want to make a better future
for people like i don't really want to
want a new car
but i do want to want to spend time with
my family so insight number one is you
can't stop wanting and i'm not sure that
i want to which leads directly to
insight number two which is
but maybe you can help steer what you
want
this may be as better stated as it is
hard to control
what you want like you cannot do it
through sheer force of will i can't just
say i want to stop one in coca-cola
and i want to start wanting to volunteer
all the time that's what i want to want
but i don't want that i want to drink
coca-cola and watch tick tocks but i
have found that there are things that i
can do to alter my wants like if i want
to work more on crash course
i have to think about education i have
to like listen
to education podcasts and talk to people
who are thinking hard about
how to make college more accessible the
more time i spend engaging with those
questions
the more i actually want to do it and if
i want to spend more time with my family
i have to spend more time with my family
like the more i do it the more i want to
do it because by spending time doing it
i'm teaching myself a story about the
value of those things what i actually
see really often is people
engaging with certain kinds of content
and not noticing
how it steers their wants like the
content is enjoyable no doubt about that
but
what is it doing to my wants like there
are a lot of people who consume content
about how to be more successful in
business and get rich
and when you consume that content you
value being successful in business and
getting rich more and the more people
who spend time watching people play
video games professionally the more
people start to value
those particular skills of professional
video game play
also there are a lot of people who
engage with content about how to be more
beautiful and the more you engage with
that content the more you value beauty
now this is just
one of the ways that you increase your
want in something like
there's two other big ones one is it is
good like it's good to have money there
is security there playing video games is
fun
fashion and makeup are art and the
second reason is that we live in a
society where those things are really
highly praised and so the barrier to
wanting those things is low
and so we are more likely to be
interested in consuming that kind of
content and i don't think it's wrong to
want these things
i do think that it can be limiting if
it's the only thing we allow ourselves
to want can we either ignore those ones
completely if we're not interested in
them
or diversify from there and this is hard
because the barrier to wanting something
gets a lot higher
when society prizes it less the less you
engage with the story the harder it is
to want that thing and if there aren't a
lot of stories about that thing
it becomes really hard to want it and in
a way
this means that the most successful
people in our society are kind of
the least interesting they're just
really good at going after the default
things society is telling them to want
now sometimes those people can become
stories themselves
that alter societal once overall but
usually not which is all a way of saying
that if you prize just a little bit
of interesting or weird if that's the
story you're into
which i am and that's like a baseline
story that you can always believe in
that prevents you from getting stuck in
these societal ruts
not that i'm always great at it it's
very easy to get stuck in there and it
is very hard for me to steer my not in
substantial want but i'm gonna keep
trying because i feel like i'm getting
better at it
and i feel like the results are positive
john i'll see you on tuesday